بات الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
متهما باساءه التعامل مع وثائق سريه في
تطور ملحوظ يجعله اول رئيس في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده يواجه اتهامات جنائيه من
قبل الحكومه الفيدراليه التي اشرف عليها
ذات مره هذا وكشف مصدر مطلع لرويترز ان
هيئه محلفين اتحاديه كبرى وجهت اتهامات
لاحتفاضه بوثائق حكوميه سريه وعرقله سير
العداله وانه سيواجه سبعه تهم جنائيه في
القضيه الاتحاديه وقال المصدر انه تم
ابلاغه فريق ترامب القانوني بالتهم ضمن
استدعاء يامر ترامب بالمثول امام المحكمه
الثلاثاء المقبل في ميامي بدوره قال محامي
ترامب في حديث مع شبكه
تشمل التامر والادلاء بتصريحات كاذبه
وعرقله سير العداله والاحتفاظ بوثائق سريه
بشكل غير قانوني بموجب قانون التجسس
قال الرئيس الامريكيه سابق دونالد ترامب
بانه طلب منه المثول امام المحكمه
الفيدراليه في ميامي يوم الثلاثاء المقبل
في اطار التحقيق حول وثائق البيت الابيض
واصفا ذلك بيوم اسود في تاريخ الولايات
المتحده مصدر مطلع كشف ان ترامب يواجه
سبعه من جنائيه للرئيس الامريكي السابق
لاحتفاضه بوثائق حكوميه سريه
وبعرقله سير العداله
وفي اول تعليق من قال الرئيس الامريكي
السابق عبر تسجيل بثوا عبر حسابه على منصه
التواصل الاجتماعي لانه بريء مضيفا انه
مستهدف بسبب الانتخابات التي يعتزم خوضها
ضد الرئيس جو بايدن
لديك رئيس حصل على اصوات اكثر من اي رئيس
في التاريخ حتى الان وهم يلاحقونني لاننا
نتقدم في استطلاعات الراي كثيرا ضد بايدن
وضد الجمهوريين نحن متقدمين ضد بايدن
كثيرا بكميات هائله وصعدنا الى مستوى حيث
اكتشفوا ان الطريقه الوحيده التي
سيوقفوننا بها هي بشن الحرب هذه حرب
باستخدام القانون لا يمكننا السماح بحدوث
ذلك بلدنا ذاهب الى الجحيم وهم يتابعون
دونالد ترامب وقاموا باستخدام وزاره العدل
ومكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي كسلاح لا
يمكننا ان ندع هذا يستمر لانه يمزق بلادنا
الى اشلاء لدينا مشاكل كبيره ولا ينبغي ان
تكون هذه واحده منها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات